[Music]
the family of Princess Diana is
preparing for a new tribute on what
would have been her 56th birthday her
son's Prince William and Prince Harry
have recently been talking publicly
about the impact of their loss tomorrow
the family will rededicate her burial
site nearly 20 years after her death
Jonathan Vigliotti is at Kensington
Palace in London Jonathan good morning
good morning Princess Diana
lived here Kensington Palace with her
two sons up until the day she died
Prince William and Prince Harry both
still live here today their home
overlooking what's known as the sunken
garden Princess Diana used to visit here
often to chat with the gardener's this
summer thousands of white flowers have
been planted in her honor
Princess Diana rests along a wooded lake
on her family's sprawling estate in
Northamptonshire her children and
grandchildren will gather here tomorrow
to mark what would have been her 56th
birthday the anniversary of Princess
Diana's death 20 years ago also marks a
milestone for her children who in the
past year have candidly opened up about
losing their mother and the pain they
still struggle with today we've never
really talked about it we've never
really talked about Prince Harry talked
with his brother Prince William and
sister aloud Kate in mate as part of
their new mental health campaign you
know even her annoying
over the years and not talked enough for
bias what's the point in bringing out
the past what's the point in bringing up
something that's only gonna make you sad
and ain't gonna change it it ain't gonna
bring her back and when you start
thinking like that it can be really
damaging just last week Prince Harry
who was 12 years old at the time
recalled the trauma of attending his
mother's funeral my mother had just died
and I had to walk a long way behind her
coffin surrounded by thousands of people
watching me while millions more did on
television he told Newsweek I don't
think any child should be asked to do
that what are your thoughts Gayle King
spoke with royal biographer Ingrid
Seward on the CBS News special
Princess Diana her life her death her
truth honey I keep thinking about her
boys today you know with the 20th
anniversary approaching and all the
different things are going to hear about
their mother and their father I think it
will be difficult for them and which is
why they've spoken out themselves when
somebody dies you will do anything to
almost keep them alive and their way of
keeping their mother alive is to carry
on the work that she started Prince
William and Prince Harry will mark this
anniversary by commissioning a statue of
their mother it will stand at this
public garden for all to see Nora Wow
Jonathan Vigliotti in London thank you
they allowed us you guys to go to her
gravesite to see it no photographs of
course but it is a very beautiful place
and it's I think it's so nice that her
sons are speaking out as difficult as it
is whatever problem have had that mother
and that father did something right to
have those two young men as their son
turned out okay
very well